Кадри того, як іспанські поліцейські
кидають на землю каталонців перед виборчими дільницями
на референдумі за незалежність автономії,
загострили кризу в Іспанії.
На ранок і місцева, і європейська преса
вийшла із заголовками про найбільшу політичну кризу
в Іспанії з часів правління Франко.
В Каталонії наполягають на успішності референдуму:
90% тих, хто прийшов на дільниці
проголосував "за",
це 2 мільйони з п’яти мільйонів трьохсот тисяч виборців.
Але ще більш вражаюча цифра -
це майже 900 поранених від дій Національної поліції та Цивільної гвардії,
підрозділи яких прибули в Каталонію з інших провінцій,
щоб протидіяти нелегальному референдуму.
Уряд Барселони вимагає, щоб всі
не-місцеві силові підрозділи негайно залишили провінцію.
І обіцяє, що протягом
48-ми годин
після оголошення остаточних результатів референдуму
місцевий парламент проголосить незалежність.
Натомість у Мадриді погрожують, що у відповідь іспанський уряд
позбавить Каталонію статусу автономії.
В Єврокомісії обидвох сторін закликали
до діалогу, а сам референдум про незалежність в Каталонії
визнали незаконним. І навіть більше -
розрив з Іспанією означатиме для каталонців
і вихід з Євросоюзу.
Згідно з іспанською Конституцією,
вчорашнє голосування у Каталонії було незаконним.
Для Єврокомісії це внутрішнє питання Іспанії,
яке треба вирішувати
згідно з конституційним ладом Іспанії.
Подібні референдуми слід організовувати відповідно до Конституції.
Якщо ж Каталонії таки вдалося б
відділитися від Іспанії, в ЄС, який не визнає
референдуму, її не візьмуть. А це суперечить обіцянкам
уряду Каталонії, більшість в якому мають праві
та ліві популісти. Вони обіцяли,
що Кaталонія швидко увійде в ЄС, а рівень доходів громадян
зросте на 40-60 відсотків.
Нині ж Каталонія "годує" Іспанію,
обурюється місцева влада.
Опоненти сепаратистів бачать ситуацію зовсім інакше.
За їхніми словами, останні 40 років Каталонія користується
такою широкою політичною автономією,
якої не мала упродовж попередніх 300 років.
І що популістські гасла живляться за рахунок тривалої
економічної кризи, від якої інші іспанські провінції
постраждали ще більше.